u.n secretary general antonia gutierrez
has warned the world is closer to
nuclear annihilation than at any other
time since the cold war he spoke at a
u.n conference on reducing the spread of
nuclear weapons the non-proliferation
meeting was postponed for two years
because of the pandemic
the stakes are high as the month-long
conference gets underway at the united
nations headquarters in new york
russia put its nuclear forces on alert
after it invaded ukraine
the un's chief said the threat posed by
nuclear weapons today hasn't been seen
since the cold war
and he issued this
warning we have been extraordinarily
lucky so far but luck is not a strategy
nor is it a shield from geopolitical
tensions boiling over into nuclear
conflict
today humanity is just one
misunderstanding when miscalculation
away from nuclear annihilation
we need the treaty of nonproliferation
of nuclear weapons as much as ever
germany's foreign minister accused
russia of reckless rhetoric and reminded
signatories of their obligations to the
non-proliferation treaty or npt
we are here
to defend the rules-based international
order
the npt
is not just the piece of paper
it embodies some of the most fundamental
commitments of humankind
to prevent the spread of nuclear weapons
to ensure nuclear weapons are never used
again
and to work towards our common goal
of a world free of nuclear weapons
in a letter to delegates moscow said
nuclear war should never be unleashed
and there could be no winners
the treaty is the cornerstone of global
efforts to stop the spread of nuclear
weapons
over the following weeks participants
will discuss a consensus on future steps
japan is spearheading talks as the
world's first and only country to be hit
with atomic bombs
the push for agreement comes days ahead
of the 77th anniversary of those nuclear
attacks
well dw's michaela kufner joins me from
outside the united nations in new york
so michaela you've been listening to a
range of high-level speeches there from
these leaders today what were the main
takeaways
well most of i was actually following
the german foreign minister and she also
sat down with a group of leaders the
stockholm group who spearhead those
efforts to really get a diplomacy going
to really mean non-proliferation when
the world talks about it and she pretty
much concluded with the sentence saying
well we're not here because it's easy
we're here because it's needed and that
was only emphasized through the speech
we heard from antonio guterres
that this is not just about intent this
is not just about
vladimir putin who in the early days of
the aggression against ukraine also
threatened the west of um
of nuclear weapons
potentially
but that the biggest risk was making
mistakes that mistakes could lead to the
annihilation essentially of mankind
these are very big words these are very
big threats
and here there are some concrete talks
to try and find ways to at least limit
them if you can't stop them
and what is the united nations hoping
will come out of this review of the
non-proliferation treaty
well
in plain words to bring
world leaders um who have nuclear arms
to their senses and um there's a lot of
finger pointing towards north korea
towards iran where the german foreign
minister called on iran to basically
take that deal that is on the table
so-called iran nuclear deal the jcpoa
and actually make this happen now and
although there were some positive
signals and
we've heard a fresh warning from anthony
blinken the u.s secretary of state who
expects yet another nuclear test by
north korea
so the hope is that and there's a month
of talks that will now be going on to
find ways to limit um the spread of
nuclear weapons and also to get some
fresh commitments to limit the number of
nuclear weapons because the so-called
start two agreement that runs out in
2026 that sounds it feels a long time
away but these talks are always very
lengthy
and they're very important indeed for
global security okay michaela couffner
in new york thank you so much michaela